fan outrage didn't just start in the
twitter era get ready to learn about the
x-files episode that was too gross the
seinfeld finale outcry and more 90s tv
moments that had fans fuming
the x-files is no stranger to unnatural
horrors throughout most of the 90s it
shocked aud delighted and disgusted its
devoted fan base with stories featuring
supernatural terrors extraterrestrial
threats and other disturbing subject
matter and perhaps no other episode
generated quite as much controversy as
1996's home part of the show's fourth
season the horrifying events in this
particular episode stemmed not from
alien appendages or paranormal palms but
human hands home kicks off with
protagonists fox mulder and dana scully
investigating the circumstances behind
the death of a deformed baby this leads
them to the peacocks a family with some
truly gruesome secrets it turns out that
there are actually three inbred brothers
who are hiding the existence of their
quadruple amputee mother who had been
breeding with them over the years by the
end of the episode she and one of her
children successfully escape ready to
grow their family once again the sheer
gruesomeness of home earned it a tvma
rating upon its debut a first in the
history of american tv programming fans
and network executives found the episode
so revolting that fox took it out of
circulation for three years
the episode isn't without its defenders
though the av club for one included it
on a list of 10 must-see episodes of the
x-files in a 2012 article you know your
boy would do anything for his mother
for most of its run the abc sitcom
roseanne enjoyed fairly stable
popularity and reviews it featured the
blue collar life of roseanne connor and
her family and it resonated with
audiences thanks to its relatability and
surprisingly progressive ways of
tackling real world themes and then
season 9 aired and everything went
completely off the rails this was the
final season of the show's original run
before it was rebooted in 2018 and the
big change was due to the conor's
winning the lottery
we won the lottery
this is the winning lottery ticket i've
got it right here remember you told me
to watch it on tv why are you talking we
won the lottery from ordinary working
class struggles the show's focus shifted
to pop culture parody and a
self-conscious approach additionally
roseanne's husband dan was sidelined for
most of the season explained away by
subplots involving him taking care of
his mother and cheating on his wife the
finale didn't offer much satisfaction it
completely invalidated the entire season
by revealing that it was all happening
in roseanne's imagination dan had
actually died from a heart attack after
season 8. the connors didn't really win
the lottery and roseanne was actually
writing her memoir as she spiraled
further down into sadness it was the
show's lowest rated season and it left a
bad taste in fans mouths that wasn't
fully washed away until the revival
undid some of the most hated decisions
lasting 9 seasons from 1989 to 1998
seinfeld was one of the most successful
and beloved american sitcoms of the
decade featuring comedian jerry seinfeld
delivering his signature brand of
observational humor the so-called show
about nothing featured him and his three
friends george elaine and kramer in
mundane situations that brought out the
best or worst in them in new york city
one infamous example was the 1997
episode the puerto rican day which
invited a ton of backlash to the show's
doorstep the premise was simple enough
the main characters found themselves
unable to move through traffic because
of the city's puerto rican day parade
this triggered a series of events that
led to kramer accidentally burning the
puerto rican flag with a sparkler the
outrage in response to that moment was
swift and tremendous and it offended
many new yorkers particularly the
hispanic population this was enough for
colombia tristar to knock it out of
circulation in new york for almost 5
years
among all the reasons why fans would
feel angry and betrayed by their
favorite tv show you would think that
the lead character getting a haircut
would be pretty low on the list but
that's not how things turned out for
carrie russell star of the wb's college
set drama felicity in one episode that
aired in 1999 she cut off her famous
curly hair which seemingly summoned to
the apocalypse in a 2017 interview with
w magazine russell noted that the
haircut was intended to be part of the
character's post-breakup actions in the
series and while the actress herself
enjoyed her new hairstyle she quickly
realized that the fans didn't share that
opinion as she put it i did not expect
all the hysteria strangers did come up
to me on the street and say things like
you were so pretty before you cut your
hair the show's ratings reportedly
plummeted to the point that wb
entertainment president suzanne daniels
believed that the haircut turned off
many of the show's male fans as she put
it you deluded that icon i think it
turned some of the audience away in
particular men and some women the move
generated so much negative buzz that
it's even been immortalized in
contemporary lexicon as pulling a
felicity
move it's like a whole new you
if you take a look at rotten tomatoes
scoreboard for each year of buffy the
vampire slayer you'll notice that season
6 sits at the bottom with 63 percent
this isn't just a case of critics being
overly critical as recounted by vanity
fair the sixth season of the iconic
supernatural 90s show was also the most
hated by its fans for numerous reasons
for an important bit of perspective
season five ended with sarah michelle
geller's title character heroically
sacrificing herself to save the world
season 6 then dealt with her friends
attempting to bring her back and
eventually succeeding however the series
took an overall depressing tone mired
with weird plot twists gratuitous sex
and a protagonist who had trouble
dealing with her resurrection to make
matters worse the cast reportedly had
difficulty communicating their issues
with the story to show runner joss
whedon who was busy balancing his
workload with two other shows in
addition to buffy fans even coined a
pair of derogatory nicknames for the
less than stellar season season sex and
season sucks
debuting in 1994 the abc sitcom ellen
featured the day-to-day life of a
30-something bookstore owner as she
balanced the little struggles and
triumphs of life in los angeles it
catapulted its star future talk show
host ellen degeneres to super stardom
this was for two main reasons for one it
was the vehicle for many viewers to get
acquainted with her quirky sense of
humor and furthermore the show made
history by having its main character
reveal her true sexual orientation at
around the same time the actor playing
her did so in real life unsurprisingly
this move prompted both congratulations
and controversy the plan to have the
on-screen ellen come out on the show had
been in the works since 1996 and so in
1997's two-part the puppy episode she
admits the truth to her love interest
susan played by laura dern via an
unintentional and humorous public
declaration
susan
i'm
[Applause]
gay puppy episode garnered 42 million
viewers becoming the highest rated
outing of the series degeneres's bold
move earned the episode in the show many
accolades awards and recognition
unfortunately it also drew the ire of
multiple advertisers and religious
groups as well as angry fans who
reportedly sent hate mail and even
threatened to bomb the production both
degeneres and dern suffered career
setbacks after the episode aired
although they've since managed to
recover and continue to work on popular
projects
sometimes a tv show has a premise so
fundamentally problematic you wonder how
it ever made it onto the air in the
first place consider the case of heil
honey i'm home a british sitcom that
followed a fictionalized adolf hitler
and ava braun as a quirky couple in a
corny 1950s inspired setting their
next-door neighbors were a jewish couple
called the goldensteins only one episode
aired in 1990 before a combination of
behind the scenes disagreements
production woes and protests from groups
offended by the idea of trivializing
hitler took it off the air completely in
a 2017 interview with entertainment
weekly series creator jeff atkinson
explained the thought process behind the
show the idea was that he wanted to beat
the bully by laughing at him as he puts
it if you have a monster like that and
everyone says you can't make fun of him
then we've made him even more of a
monster that's what fascists want to
keep people in fear of them when surely
we should be debunking and destroying
them
in december 1997 hundreds of children in
japan tuned in to get their regular dose
of pokemon but by the end of this
particular episode they found themselves
experiencing seizures and in the days
that followed many more were rushed to
hospitals the root of this medical
emergency was a six second sequence of
bright flashing lights the episode
entitled electric soldier porygon
generated so much controversy that the
show aired no new episodes for four
months the series was ultimately saved
from the jaws of cancellation but
nintendo ended up banning the episode in
all countries furthermore the pokemon
character porygon and its evolutions
have yet to appear or display their
powers on the show since the incident
and that's not the end of the story a
2001 study looked into the incident and
found that the cases of children
suffering seizures after the episode
aired may not have been due to epilepsy
instead they were likely the result of
mass hysteria a phenomenon in which
people experience severe physical
symptoms due to stress or a perceived
threat
sometimes even the most well-intentioned
attempts at social awareness can
backfire especially when you attempt
them in a children's cartoon one major
example is the 1991 tiny toon adventures
episode elephant issues whose satirical
segment about the dangers of drunk
driving caused it to be banned from
reruns on fox kids the episode's third
short entitled one beer features buster
bunny plucky duck and hampton j pig
engaging in some car stealing
shenanigans after drinking a single
bottle of beer as soon as they got
intoxicated they managed to carjack a
police vehicle then they end up driving
off a cliff seemingly killing themselves
and ascending into heaven as angels but
then the true punchline arrives seconds
later when the camera pants to reveal
the three characters alive and unscathed
in a studio the whole thing was just a
scripted gag to teach kids about the
horrors of alcohol despite its important
message and clear self-awareness it was
taken off the air and rarely rebroadcast
reportedly due to backlash from parents
however it did eventually make it onto
the third volume of the tiny toons
adventures dvd collection that was
released in 2013.
nobody really has high expectations
concerning morality and ethics when it
comes to beavis and butthead the mtv
cartoon influenced an entire generation
with its crass and irreverent brand of
humor it's no surprise that a number of
episodes have been edited or even
outright banned but there's one
particularly infamous episode that was
completely removed from circulation due
to a real world tragedy it allegedly
inspired as reported by the new york
times a five-year-old boy from ohio who
saw the 1993 episode comedians set his
family's mobile home on fire a month
later leading to the death of his
younger sister the episode features the
title characters burning down a comedy
club and the boy's mother claimed that
the episode promoted the idea that
playing with fire was fun
when the local nbc station reported on
the story they asked some viewers of the
show who they thought for responsibility
i don't think it's mtv's fault at all i
think it's a parent's ball for maybe
letting kids like five years old
watching the show notably this wasn't
the first time that the show was
associated with a real world fire in
ohio as there was an incident months
earlier in which three young girls
nearly burned their house down according
to the police they admitted that a
beavis and butt head gag inspired them
to use an aerosol can and a match to set
clothing on fire
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you